Apple's iPhone 15 Pro is coming in less
than three months with perhaps the most
hyped up chip ever the a17 bionic and
unfortunately we have some bad news but
don't worry there's plenty of other good
news to get excited about which I'm
going to discuss in this video so let's
jump right into the latest leaks first
of all apple is apparently going to make
two different versions of the same a17
chip which they've never ever done
before to help cut costs and I'm going
to explain that in just a minute but
first I've got to talk about this quite
disappointing tweet from Tech read he's
been leaking a lot of different info in
terms of apples chips and products over
the last few months and check out this
tweet it says I seem to have mentioned
outdated info about the M3 and he's
referring to this leaked M3 chip
Benchmark for May 27th with some really
really good scores but now he's saying
the ace 17 and M3 are not new
architectures but rather improvements in
the manufacturing process to three
nanometer should we refer to it as M2
Plus instead it's quite disappointing so
basically when Apple redesigns a chip
and brings it to a new process node they
can either do a full new architecture
that's optimized for that smaller node
with more transistors or they can
basically take this same architecture
and just kind of translate it over to
the new process node three nanometer but
it's not going to be nearly as efficient
or as performant so apparently according
to him the new M3 and a17 chips are not
going to be as good as we thought and
especially as good as those leaked
benchmarks that we got before like this
one showing the a17 ship in geekbench 6
with a single core score of over 3 000
and multi core of
78.60 that's basically M1 chip
performance in an iPhone and he says
here apple and tsmc are King they make
the best chips together that's a crazy
score but he's saying it's not going to
be that good apparently however this is
a little bit sketchy because those
scores were actually pretty tame because
if we look at geekbench 6 and the a16
bionic chip it's performing very well
already if we divide that new score by
the a16 we get only a 20 jump in single
core performance which actually makes a
lot of sense and then doing the same
thing for the multi-core dividing that
leaked score to the a16 bionic we get a
Improvement that also makes sense I was
actually expecting a lot bigger
improvements so honestly just looking at
those League scores they seem to be the
ones that we are getting so maybe it
could have been better before Apple
decided to kind of tone it down and not
do a full architecture redesign so I'm
personally hoping for the best but let's
move on to the next leak which is this
apple reportedly switching the
technology into two different
Technologies for the same a17 bionic
chip apparently Apple's been working on
their original Three nanometer node
called n3b which is supposed to be be
really good customized and optimized
super efficient but the problem is the
yield is quite low so apparently next
year when the regular iPhone 16 gets the
a17 chip that a17 is not going to be as
good it's going to be using the n3e
which is apparently more accessible to
the other clients that tsmc have already
so it's not going to be as good it's
going to have fewer euv layers and lower
transistor density than n3b resulting in
efficiency trade-offs but the process
can apparently provide better
performance so it could have worse
battery life that a17 chip in the iPhone
16 model so it's interesting that apple
is doing this to save money and now
let's move on to the next big
disappointment with the EU and apple but
first I've got to give a shout out to
our partner cascu for their magic stand
case we which is the best value case you
can get since it's very rugged high
quality and stylish while also featuring
magnets for all of your magsafe
accessories but making it even better
the macsafe ring is actually on a hinge
that works as a finger grip and a stand
at a variety of different angles for
things like watching videos or even
taking photos so go ahead and check out
the discount info and Link in the
description below and here we are on
Apple tracks Twitter and he's saying
that the EU May Force Apple to radically
redesign the iPhone by a
2027. apparently a new mandate states
that smartphone batteries must be easily
removable and replaceable by the user
and obviously the iPhone does not have
user replaceable batteries basically
ever so they're trying to make a new law
and this is no joke you can literally go
onto the European Parliament website and
read it for for yourself portable
batteries and appliances will be easier
to replace designing portable batteries
and appliances in such a way that
consumers can themselves easily remove
and replace them and that is for the EU
this is getting crazy because the EU has
been giving Apple a lot of trouble they
even warned Apple about limiting the
speed of uncertified USBC cables for
iPhones which was actually in the leaks
and they're probably the main reason why
apple is going with USBC in the first
place because they have mandated put
into law that all phones sold in the EU
have to have USBC by the fall of 2024 so
apple is moving forward a little bit
early later this year with the iPhone 15
Pro but apple is going to be a little
bit tricky because apparently you can
only get the fastest transfer speeds
with the IP phone 15 Pro Models yes that
means that the regular iPhone 15s are
going to be using the older USB 2.0
speeds which is basically the same as
Lightning super super slow but don't
worry there's actually some good news to
talk about as well which is going to
make a lot of you guys want to wait for
these new iPhone 15 models the first
piece of good news is this from Ming
Chico just a few days ago he says the
iPhone 15 is getting a Next Generation
Ultra wide band chip for enhanced Vision
Pro headset integration so you guys know
the Vision Pro headset is coming next
year and this is going to basically use
less power the new chip is gonna have
advanced seven nanometer process
technology from tsmc moving on from 16
nanometers so it's going to have reduced
power consumption which means means they
can use that Ultra wideband ship a lot
more often without wasting a lot of the
battery life like right now it's being
used for location tracking find my
Precision finding airdrop in a bunch of
other things and then even better next
year with the iPhone 16 that's finally
gonna support Wi-Fi 7 which is
definitely something to look forward to
but for now this year it looks like we
are expecting Wi-Fi 6E to come on the
iPhone 15 models which is actually very
exciting because it's a big deal with
the new six gigahertz band and other
good news we are getting the dynamic
Island on all of the iPhone 15 models
this year so the notch is officially
going away forever we will never see it
again and then even better the new
Dynamic island is actually going to
include a new integrated proximity
sensor built right into the island
itself so like it's going to be more
accurate and look at light and examine
it a lot better than it currently does
because right now it's underneath the
display and then an even better news for
the iPhone 15 Pro Models it looks like
we can actually get Thunderbolt 3 Port
support on those models which means
insanely fast transfer speeds I mean
insanely fast however Tech Reeve did say
that the iPhone 15 Pro Series is going
to support USBC 3.2 speeds but maybe
that's just support and it is going to
have Thunderbolt on top of that let's
hope so and then of course a big piece
of news that I recently talked about was
that the 15 Pro Max model is going to be
getting a telephoto Periscope camera
with variable Zoom that means inside of
the actual camera itself it's going to
be able to zoom dynamically from let's
say 3x to 5x using physical lenses not
just digital zoom and that's going to be
a huge deal and my favorite part that
I'm really looking forward to with the
new iPhone 15 Pro Models is thin bezels
because apparently the 15 Pro Max is
gonna have the thinnest bezels in any
smartphone ever and I can't wait to see
it so with all that said here are my
thoughts I think this is going to be a
killer upgrade even if the a17 chip
isn't quite as good as it could be it's
still going to be a good upgrade and I
think the battery life is going to be
amazing alongside all of these other
awesome upgrades I can't wait for it and
if you can't wait either let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign